et cet invité aujourd'hui assez vous
andreï kourkov bonjour bonjour bienvenue
sur ce plateau vous êtes écrivain bien
connu ukrainien d'origine russe votre
premier roman le pingouin a connu un
succès mondial et vous publiez les
abeilles grise qui sort demain ici en
france c'est que j'ai ici chez liana
levi dans lesquels on suit un apiculteur
englué avec ses abeilles dans une guerre
absurde
tiens tiens on y revient dans un instant
l'ukraine on en parlait à l'instant
andreï kourkov et malgré elle depuis des
semaines au coeur de l'actualité
internationale menacée à sa frontière
par des dizaines de milliers de soldats
russes que washington soupçonne de
vouloir traverser et envahir le pays
qu'est ce qu'on est en train de vivre
selon vous oui en fait il n'y a pas de
panique en ukraine les cafés les restera
là qu'ils vivent sont complets l'air est
normal mais bien sûr beaucoup des gens
sont préparées pour la guerre et
beaucoup dé gens maintenant font des
cures de défense territoriale
en droit et on peut rejoindre comme si
les listes en groupe pour défendre sa
ville son village et aussi il ya
beaucoup de cours d aide médicale dans
la cas de guerre mais oui c'est mais la
guerre est dure déjà 80 cc lacq en
finition des guerres et des guerres de
dôme bas ça me fait est ce qu'on croit
vraiment en ukraine parce que ces temps
ci on parle beaucoup de la russie des
états unis de ce qu'en pense le temps on
entend assez peu ce qu'on pense les
ukrainiens en réalité est ce qu'on croit
vraiment en ukraine aujourd'hui que
vladimir poutine va faire traverser ses
soldats je crois 30 35% des ukrainiennes
croient que la guerre est possible et 60
% de 65 sont pas sûrs ou ne crois pas il
y a effectivement vous l'avez rappelé
des précédents la crim est annexée en
2014 par moscou et dont le sort suscite
une indifférence assez générale il ya ce
conflit dans le donbass ou le cessez le
feu et res et
très régulièrement violée c'est là que
vous campez ce roman les abeilles grise
précisément dans une zone grise est-ce
que vous pouvez nous expliquer dans quel
endroit on est exactement enfin la zone
crise à la même longueur que la ligne de
front ses
430 km c'est l'un des freins john bass
où il y a quarante cinquante mille des
célèbres aignan si tu as it est hélas il
ya des bombardements des des activités
militaires chaque jour c'est à dire il
ya beaucoup de gens qui restaient dans
le village presque abandonnés ou
abandonnés il ya aussi des parties des
petites villes qui sont dans la zone
grise
c'est à dire qui est un côté habité par
les armes et l'autre côté de la ville et
vite et là il ya des batailles c'est une
espèce de no man's land et on le ressent
en lisant un vous lisant on m'a défendu
aussi lourde et semble suspendu où on ne
sait même plus trop vraiment qui est
l'ennemi
en fait les gens qui habitent là pour
eux les deux côtés son ennemi parce que
il y a des gens des deux côtés qui
parfois entre dans deux villages à part
ramène quelque chose pour ces gens et
pour ces gens la chose principale et
survivre dans cette guerre et il ne
comprend pas souvent pourquoi
sa guerre n'est pas finie
qu'est ce que ce qu'est ce que cet état
de fait ce no man's land die de
l'ukraine
d'aujourd'hui est ce qu'une partie des
ukrainiens ont fait le deuil de cette
partie du don base de la crimée à tout
jamais ou est ce qu il reste encore
quelque chose on reste en fait il ya
beaucoup de gens qui sont très
émotionnel à propos la guerre à propos
d'une basse et c'est aussi la fois des
politiciens ukrainiens qui ne pouvait
pas intégrer les régions d'ukraine
différents dans un vraiment pays solides
et le droit c'était toujours séparés de
créer une centrale de créer ouest avec
une mentalité spéciale plus collective
que dans galicie ou bukovine et c'était
aussi un peu plus nostalgique sur la vie
politique toujours comme ça et c'est
c'est
il ya des émotions très différent il ya
des gens qui n'acceptent pas de base
comme l'ukraine mais c'est la minorité
radicale pour la majorité c'est au cren
propre c'est les pays des cosaques aussi
et c'est bien sûr c'était la région très
industrielle très importante pour
l'économie au crayon et puis la crimée a
aussi vous en parlez dans votre livre
une valeur sentimentale pour beaucoup
d'ukrainiens c'était un lieu de vacances
au lieu de navilly passait chaque était
en moi et toi tu aurais ya 7 c c'était
une ville pour les familles pour les
vacances avec des enfants est en fait
2014 j'étais là à la dernière fois avec
ma famille ce n'est plus possible
jean-louis comment s'écrit justement
comment est-ce qu'on veut écrire un
récit national dans ces conditions à ce
qu'est la ligne de fracture est ce
qu'elle est géographique est ce qu'elle
est démographique est ce qu'elle est
générationnel entre ces deux ukraine qui
peut-être ne se comprennent pas ou plus
pour moi en fait c'est la frontière
entre la mentalité soviétique horus
collectif et la mentalité traditionnels
ukrainiens
individualiste un peu anarchique parfois
il ya vente en face en ligne coupet
l'ukraine en deux mais aujourd'hui elle
s'allie se trouve à deux bars en fait et
je n'ai rassure il ya des différences
entre les générations parce que les
nouveaux ou craignent les jeunes
ukrainiens sont très européen ils n'ont
pas
nostalgie sur la vie soviétique et ils
n'en savent rien enfin soulagé
soviétique pour eux le crains c'est une
partie du groupe parce qu'ils voyagent
beaucoup et il se trouve toujours à
paris
à londres et comme ça c'est la question
des mentalités c'est la guerre des deux
mentalités parce que en fait la
mentalité russe était arrivé en ukraine
avec la lame douce avec russification et
maintenant la langue ou qui viendrait
prendre les territoires et pousse la
natalité ukrainienne vers l'est est ce
que c'est de là que viennent vos
personnages ceux qui habitent vos romans
celui-ci comme le pingouin qui est des
personnages qui sont toujours un peu
seul un peu perdue face au système face
qui ont du mal à trouver leur place sont
ceux du monde d'hier c'est ça c'est ça
vous avez couvert du moins
écrit quoi sur la révolution orange puis
sur la régulation du du maidan
ce livre là est un roman qu'est ce que
la fiction apporte qu'un récit peut-être
plus journalistique ne peut pas apporter
pour raconter précisément une réalité
comme celle du dombass aujourd'hui je
crois avec fiction on peut plus
facilement
provoquer des attitudes des dépenses et
des gens
sachent enfin pousse les gens d analyser
la situation et comparer sa vie avec la
vie des protagonistes de livres et pour
comprendre aussi les régions qui sont
décrits dans ce livre bio vous était
andrzej pourquoi venez en russie vous
êtes russophone vous écrivez en russe
vos romans pourquoi est-ce que vous
n'écrivez pas en ukrainien je crois que
ça vous est reproché et côté russe
notamment de la frontière enfin mes
livres ne sont pas disponibles ici il ya
peut-être jusqu'à 40 45 % des ukrainiens
qui parle russe parfois dans la famille
parle russe dans des rues ou chrétiennes
ou dans d'autres au crayon mais pour moi
c'est important d'écrire dans la langue
maternelle j'ai appris le craignait dans
l'âge de 14 ans c'est à dire c'est une
langue c'est un peu
je parle sans accent mais ça reste pour
moi on peut être âgé parce que bien sûr
les écrivains qui écrivent naturellement
en ukrainien
ils peuvent dire beaucoup plus parce que
il ya des sensations il ya des dix
nations des musiques des langues dans la
sangle pour moi bien sûr ça la langue
comme ça ça reste le russe comment est
ce que vous voyez peut-être à titre
personnel
les années qui vont arriver sachant que
je ne sais pas ce qu'il ya aujourd'hui
dans la tête du voisin russe a fortiori
dans celle de vladimir poutine est-ce
qu'il renoncera la halle à
la façon dont il considère l'ukraine
comme étant toujours quasiment russes
comment quelle est la porte de sortie
comment est ce que est ce que c'est
forcément en allant côté européen claque
l'ukraine à sang le crâne après la
décision ou
crème veut aller vers où est-ce parce
que bien sûr la choix est entre
avec l'adie contrôlée par l'état comme
dans l'union soviétique à leur régime
des policiers en fait et la vie plus
naturelle pour le co2 les ukrainiens
c'est la vie libres pour les hautes
fagnes liberté est plus important que
stabilité pour les russes c'est une
autre chose stabilité est plus important
que la liberté et c'est vraiment ces
deux nations différents qui étaient
ensemble pour plus de 300 ans enfin à
cause des
histoires des histoires entre pologne et
turquie parce que traîne pendant deux
trois ans dans le siècle 15e 16e et 17e
siècles c'était les territoires libres
avec des élections libres au centre art
avec get man qui étaient les chefs
d'armée et nous par les cosaques et par
l'élite c'est à dire c'était déjà
7e siècle un pays démocratique mais à
quel moment pensez vous que le voisin
russe va laisser l'ukraine vivre ça
destin européen s'ils sont et s'il
devient on fatigue et on fait des pas
des combats des guerres parce que russie
ait jamais fatigué des faits réels mais
enfin j'espère qu'elle est les peuples
de russie de viande fatigué de d'être
vus comme les ennemis des voisins c'est
pas normal en fait être encerclée par
les ennemis comme journaliste russe
souvent dit qu'est ce que tu dises que
la russie a encerclé par les ennemis par
par les pays
qui sont agressifs vers la russie merci
beaucoup et andreï kourkov dette revenu
ce matin sur le plateau de paris direct
donc les abeilles les abeilles grise qui
sort demain chez liana levi traduit du
russe pour le coup en français par paul
le guen qu'on salue merci encore